Lo que quiero hacer en este video es hablar un
poco sobre la espectrofotometría, lo cual suena
bastante sofisticado pero en realidad se basa en
un principio bastante simple. Digamos que tenemos
dos soluciones que contienen algún tipo de soluto:
esta es la solución 1 y esta es la solución 2,
y supongamos que nuestros tubos de ensayo tienen
el mismo ancho. Ahora digamos que la solución 1
tiene menos soluto. Voy a dibujar la línea del
líquido así y voy a poner pocas líneas mostrando
que este tubo tiene una menor concentración;
digamos que es de color amarillo, así que esto
tiene menos. Y digamos que la solución número 2
tiene más del soluto, así que lo represento como
líneas más concentradas, entonces la concentración
del soluto es mayor aquí. Voy a escribirlo: mayor
concentración, y esta otra tiene una concentración
menor: menor concentración. Ahora pensemos en lo
que sucederá si iluminamos cada uno de estos
tubos, y supongamos que el soluto que disolvimos
aquí brilla en una longitud de onda específica
a la que es específicamente sensible. Pero no
entraré en detalles ahora. Entonces digamos que
tengo un rayo de luz aquí de cierta intensidad,
llamémoslo Intensidad incidente y 0 ¿Qué va a
pasar cuando la luz salga por el otro lado de
este tubo? Bueno, parte de ella será absorbida por
las pequeñas moléculas dentro del tubo de ensayo,
así que del otro lado saldrá menos luz. Llamaré
a esto I₁. Ahora, en esta situación, si dirigimos
la misma cantidad de luz en este tubo de ensayo,
en ambos casos habrá la misma intensidad de luz.
¿Qué va a pasar? Bueno, la luz se absorberá
más a medida que viaja a través de este tubo,
simplemente va a chocar con más moléculas
porque aquí hay una concentración más alta.
Entonces la luz que sale cuando pasa por una
concentración más alta la llamaré Intensidad 2,
I₂. I₂ va a tener una menor intensidad de luz
transmitida en comparación con la intensidad de
la luz que sale aquí. En este caso I₂ va a tener
una intensidad más baja que la intensidad de I₁.
Si tuviéramos otro tubo que sea quizás el doble de
ancho, y digamos que tiene la misma concentración
de soluto que el número 2, lo llamaremos número
3. Y ahora vamos a dirigir el mismo rayo de luz
al tercer tubo. Por lo general nos vamos a
interesar en las frecuencias de luz que se
absorben mejor por las partículas del soluto,
pero digamos que haces pasar la misma luz aquí
y tienes algo de luz que sale del otro lado
del tubo, esto es lo que verían tus ojos. A
esta salida de luz la llamamos I₃. ¿Qué crees que
va a pasar? Pues tiene la misma concentración,
pero la luz tiene que recorrer una mayor distancia
en esta concentración, de nuevo chocará con más
moléculas y más luz será absorbida, por lo que se
transmitirá menos luz. Entonces I₂ es menor que
I₃, e I₃ en realidad será la menor. Y si estuviera
mirando la luz de salida: esta tiene la menor luz,
esta tiene un poco más de luz y esta tiene la
mayor cantidad de luz transmitida. Entonces,
si miras esto, si colocas tu ojo aquí mismo,
este de aquí tendría el color más claro,
llegará la mayor cantidad de luz a tu ojo,
este tendrá un color ligeramente más oscuro
y este tendrá el color más oscuro. Eso tiene
mucho sentido. Si disuelves un poco de algo el
agua seguirá siendo bastante transparente, si
disuelves mucho de algo el agua será más opaca
y si el recipiente en donde estás disolviendo
ese algo es más grande el agua se volverá aún
más opaca. Espero que esto les dé una idea de
lo que está detrás de la espectrofotometría. La
siguiente pregunta es ¿para qué sirve?, ¿por qué
nos interesa? Bueno, puedes usar esta información
que obtienes de ver cuánta luz se transmite en
comparación con la cantidad que introduces para
calcular la concentración real de una solución.
Es por eso que estamos hablando de esto en el
contexto de Química. Entonces, antes de hacer esto
-y les mostraré un ejemplo en el siguiente video-,
permítanme definir algunos términos usados para
las mediciones de la concentración de algo o de
cuánta luz se transmite en relación a cuánto se
agregó al líquido. Lo primero que voy a definir
es la transmitancia. Aquí lo que nos interesa
es saber cuánta luz se transmite con respecto
a la luz que ingresó, y la transmitancia
está definida como esa relación. Entonces,
en este ejemplo, la transmitancia del número 1 es
la cantidad que salió entre la cantidad que entró;
en este otro caso la transmitancia es la cantidad
que salió entre la cantidad que entró. Y como
vemos esto será un número menor: I₂ es menor
que I₁, por lo que esto tiene una transmitancia
menor que el número 1. Vamos a llamar a esto
transmitancia 2, esta es la transmitancia 1,
y la transmitancia 3 es la luz que sale o que
atraviesa el líquido entre la luz que entra;
y este es el número más pequeño seguido de este,
seguido de este. Entonces esto tendrá la menor
transmitancia, es la más opaca seguida de esta
y seguida de esta. Ahora, otra definición que
está relacionada con la transmitancia y que
tiene propiedades bastante interesantes es la
noción de absorbancia. Y aquí estamos tratando de
medir qué tan bueno es absorbiendo, esto trata de
medir qué tan bueno es transmitiendo. Un número
más alto indica que está transmitiendo mucho,
pero la absorbancia se refiere a qué tan bien
está absorbiendo. Así que es todo lo contrario,
si eres bueno transmitiendo significa que eres
malo absorbiendo, no tienes mucho que absorber;
y si eres bueno absorbiendo significa que no estás
transmitiendo mucho. Esto es absorbancia. Y la
absorbancia se define como el logaritmo negativo
de la transmitancia, y este logaritmo es base 10,
o si la transmitancia ya la hemos definido será
el logaritmo negativo de la luz que se transmite
entre la luz que entra. Pero la forma más sencilla
es el logaritmo negativo de la transmitancia.
Entonces, si la transmitancia es un número
grande, la absorbancia es un número pequeño,
lo cual tiene sentido. Ahora, lo que también es
genial de esto es que hay algo llamado la Ley de
Beer-Lambert, que puedes verificar y que usaremos
en el siguiente video. La Ley de Beer-Lambert,
de hecho no conozco su origen, aunque estoy
segura de que involucra a alguien llamado Beer,
pero siempre me imaginé que esto se llamaba así
porque alguien quería medir la luz que pasa a
través de la cerveza, porque Beer es cerveza
en inglés. La Ley de Beer-Lambert nos dice que
la absorbancia es proporcional a la longitud
del camino o qué tan lejos tiene que viajar la
luz en la solución, entonces es proporcional
a la longitud del camino multiplicada por la
concentración [A ∝ i • c]. Usualmente usamos la
molaridad para la concentración. Otra forma de
decirlo es que la absorbancia es igual a una
constante, generalmente se usa una épsilon
minúscula [ε], y esto depende de la solución
o el soluto en cuestión, lo que tenemos aquí,
y de la temperatura y la presión y todo eso.
Esto es igual a una constante multiplicada
por la longitud que tiene que viajar, multiplicada
por la concentración. Permíteme hacerlo más claro:
esto de aquí es la concentración. Para saber
por qué es útil, imagina que tenemos un eje aquí
y aquí mido la concentración: este es nuestro
eje de concentración y lo estamos midiendo como
molaridad, y digamos que la molaridad comienza en
0 y sigue en 0.1, 0.2, 0.3 y así sucesivamente;
y en el eje vertical mides la absorbancia. Ahora
digamos que tienes alguna solución y conoces la
concentración, sabes que es una concentración 0.1
molar. Déjame escribir m para molar, y luego mides
su absorbencia y obtienes un número que resulta
ser una concentración baja; no absorbió tanto,
digamos que el valor es 0.25. Y luego mides otra
concentración conocida, digamos que es 0.2 molar,
y dices: "Oh, mira, aquí tiene una absorbancia de
0.5". Lo que esto te dice es que es una relación
lineal. Para cualquier concentración, la
absorbancia será una recta, y si quieres
un pequeño repaso de álgebra: ε • l será la
pendiente. Pero lo importante aquí es que tienes
una recta y esto nos es útil porque puedes usar un
poco de álgebra para calcular la ecuación de una
recta, o simplemente mirarla gráficamente y ver
que tenías dos concentraciones conocidas y puedes
calcular la absorbencia. Y entonces también puedes
hacer lo contrario: si tienes una concentración
desconocida, puedes averiguar su absorbancia.
Digamos que hay una concentración desconocida
y te das cuenta de que la absorbancia está justo
aquí, digamos que es 0.4, entonces puedes seguir
esta recta aquí y decir que eso debe tener una
concentración de esta cantidad, cualquiera que
sea, y podrías medirlo o encontrarlo usando
álgebra básica; esto estará bastante cerca de
0.2 molar, un poco menos de 0.2 molar. Y de hecho
haremos un ejemplo de esto en el próximo video.